Hmm.
What is the experience of believing in
God and how is that qualitatively,
qualitatively different from a person
who says that he doesn't?
I see what you mean by that is that is
part of the question.
The question is here while the.
When someone says,
do you believe in God?
No,
there's three parts to that question.
The first question is who is the you to
which they are referring?
Let turns out to not be it.
A simple question.
I mean Neesha did a very good job of
taking apart the idea of the eye,
you know,
because he was,
he was critiquing descartes' I think
therefore I am.
And,
and so the idea,
the first question is,
well,
who is the you to which you are
referring.
The second is what do you mean by
belief?
The third is what do you mean by God?
It's like you can't just leap to the
assumption that the person asking the
question and the person answering the
question have the same views on those
and I think that that's,
that's part of the reason why I don't
like the question.
You know,
like I said,
well I act as if I believe in God,
and so I would say that's the more,
that's the most fundamental
manifestation of faith,
but I could also say I believe and don't
believe in God and saying,
well,
you can't.
You can't think both of those things at
the same time.
It's like,
well,
hell yeah,
that's what you think.
It's,
it's,
it's in,
in.
When you were asking something that
complicated,
then there's absolutely no reason to
assume that you can't have paradoxical
responses to it.
So you could.
You could even say maybe that the
injunction in the old testament is
something like,
you should believe that not believe in
God [inaudible].
It's very complicated.
It's not.
It's not by any means.
A simple question.
I don't remember his name though,
but I think perhaps it was a burger or
something like that.
He said that myth is about reconciling
contradictions within the human.
Exactly.
That's exactly.
Well,
that's what a successful myth does and
part of the reason that these ideologies
that we've been discussing feminism
power so much power is because they
actually draw their motive force from an
underlying religious substrate,
but they only tell half the story and
that's what ended theology is.
So when the feminists say,
culture is that tyrannical patriarch,
it's like,
yeah,
that's true,
but it's also the benevolent wise king.
So like,
well then they say,
well,
I can't be one and the other at the same
time,
and the answer is,
well,
it's a multidimensional phenomena that
you're encapsulating within a single
category.
It can contain contradictions.
In fact it does because society
obviously constraints and and kills you
even like you dye into your neural
configuration because when you were
first born,
you have more neural connections than
you will ever in your life and most of
them die.
And so so you dye into your four year
old self and then between the ages of 16
and 20,
you dye into your adult self.
And so the idea that the society that
you're in is a terrible tyrant.
That shapes you by death is exactly
true,
but by the same token,
it's also almost everything that
ennobles you and enables you to function
in the world.
And so the critic,
critics of the Patriarchy say tyranny,
tyranny,
tyranny.
And it's like,
yeah,
tyranny,
but not only tyranny.
And they say evil man,
evil man.
It's like,
yeah,
obviously,
but not only evil man.
Not only that,
and that's why a genuine mythologies,
and I would put Freudian Psycho analysis
in that category because Freud had a
very balanced view of the nature of
being
talks about both parts of the paradox at
the same time,
you know,
it's the dragon and the gold.
It's the terrible devouring mother and
the,
and the Virgin Mary.
It's the tyrant and the wise king.
It's Christ and sait.
It's all of those paradoxes stacked on
top of one another.
And then the story about how you go
about dealing with them.
That's a true religious myth.
Yeah.
And,
and the dog just takes a part of that
and says,
this is the whole.
In early Christianity,
there was a large battle between many
keiths and,
uh,
the.
And what would turn out to be the
Catholic Church and the mainstream
church and,
and they said that the evil evil was the
world we live in is created by this
other force,
the demiurge so that the,
they had a very split vision of good and
evil.
But what you're saying and what you were
saying about these ideologies is that
basically it's perhaps it's a new formal
theological battle between glowsticks
and the people that say that this is,
we have both sides,
both sides.
That's a perfectly reasonable way of
looking at it,
you know,
and like young tended towards Manichaean
as to some degree because he was so
struck by say the evils of,
of have nazi-ism.
And he,
he had a hard time with the idea that
evil was only the absence of good.
But,
and I thought about that a lot because
I'm a great admirer of Yoga and you
criticize anything he said at your
peril,
you know,
because he was a great genius.
But I think that,
I think the Manichaean view is wrong.
I think that what evil is,
is the absence of good.
And then it takes on its own life.
I think it's,
I mean,
I've written about this in my new book
quite extensively because I have a book
coming out in January called 12 rules
for life,
an antidote to chaos and I'd be trying
to take those ideas apart and to grapple
with,
well,
with the fact that human beings hate
themselves because they're vulnerable
and malevolent,
which,
which is original sin,
you know,
which is something I'm a great believer
in.
Um,
I think it's an unbelievably
sophisticated way of looking at the
world.
You know,
that there's something
that,
there was something damaged in the
fabric of being itself.
I,
I believe that to be the case.
I think we experienced that as human
beings and that our ethical obligation
is to rectify that and to determine how
to rectify that,
to overcome the vulnerability and
malevolence that like the terror of
vulnerability and the subjection to
malevolence that characterizes our day
to day existence.
That's our,
that's our primary mode of proper being
in the world.
That seems to me to be correct.
So,
and again,
that's the sort of thing that I've been
trying to tell.
Well those who will listen,
let's say,
but it's so far,
it's mostly been young men who are dying
for this message.
Like they're dying for it,
you know,
it's really Connie's,
I go to these talks now,
you know,
public talks and where I speak about
responsibility and truth and like after
the talks,
there are
crowds of mostly young men who line up
and say,
you know,
I was nihilistic,
I was desperate,
I was suicidal,
I was malevolent and resentful and like
going bad places.
And I've started listening to what
you've been saying about myth and it's
like brought me out of that horrible
hole.
And it's just one person after another
says the same thing.
You know,
it's so,
and I've had thousands of letters like
that and maybe tens of thousands now I
can't even begin to keep up with them.
And well,
thank God for that.
You know.